of all the celebrity encounters you had  under his amazing turnout live years  what was your is there one that stands  out there was a moment that really  stands out which I I'm never gonna talk  show but it it was when Keith Richards  was the host okay so and Keith and so  there was a horse on the show and that  dinner break at 5:30 I was there by that  at this time cuz I was in the sketch  with that horse you okay and Keith  Randle's order for this you know I was  just the whole studio is empty the horse  Keith Richards I'm just working on some  props Keith doesn't see me I'll just  wide shot I'll walk he's I he can't see  me there's the horse here's Keith  Richards and I see him you know  staggering him to frame and he walked up  to the horse he puts the horse's head in  his hands and he says I swear to god no  he was just so good he identified the  animal  he said what it was to its face and that  was it  you